avec la coved plusieurs songent à
quitter la ville pour aller s'établir à
la campagne mais ce ne serait pas le
premier mouvement de retour à la terre
dans les années soixante dix il ya des
lieux d'importants extraits d'une
entrevue touchante avec un agriculteur
qui avait lui même vécu ce retour au
tournant des années 30
à
[Musique]
oh
moi je te ressemble à crabes à
l'agriculture dans ce sens et quand on
m'avait le sata pour ma place voici donc
je peux revenir des bonnes chances de
nous
j'aurai des mes beaux parents et d'un
j'ai pu faire là qui sur cette ferme si
elle était comment la ferme quand vous
l'avez acheté une certaine comme la tour
de tunis also que les tells 45 ans plus
jeune justement il ya des gens qui
viennent sur ceux des terres pour le
plaisir de la chose est ce que vous
pensez de ces gens là je souhaite un
terme à soin que ce soit vrai mais aussi
propice pour piste
justement est-ce que trop souvent c'est
par des gens qui viennent la ville qui
s'en viennent
oui oh oui mais dans toutes les
professions ayant dans ses rangs ce qui
va leur revenir ou changer ou le croire
et ça avis rendent à l'évidence que
comme nation pays
un coin continent ne peut pas vivre sans
sa paysannerie depuis commencement du
monde que le pays zain est nécessaire
évidemment avec le progrès la vitesse et
où on ne parle on a pour simplifier la
vie ni l'agrément et puis peut être
raison mais tout de même on a changé le
mode de filles absolument
ah si on peut pas s'improviser paysan
est ce qu'on peut se préparer à le
devenir et ce qu'on peut apprendre à le
devenir
évidemment est-ce qui est un métier qui
s'apprend pas monsieur
mais pour faire un matin combien ça
prend d'année pour faire un docteur
combien est est ce que le paysan ne doit
pas être et l'inter et d'acteurs et
charpentiers et menuisiers électriciens
aujourd'hui avec hommes d'affaires